[Music]
[Applause]
well maybe the tiebreakers Mike Golic Jr
College uh football analyst and co-host
of golo and Golic on DraftKings Network
and he was in the booth for Colorado and
Oregon what do you make of the Taylor
Swift Travis Kelsey situation
I think these are a couple of kids
trying to have fun who might be leaning
into the bit a little bit right like
we've had people looking over the
Zapruder film last night and found out
Travis is wearing an outfit into the
stadium that's from her 1989 collection
in here this announcement comes on the
day they announced the Super Bowl
halftime show she's been linked to and
now is just completely overshadowing it
in the media so there might be a little
gamesmanship but I think they're into
each other okay all right I respect that
thank you Mike that's all we wanted to
ask you about
now it's nice to be with a fellow Swifty
here Dan I appreciate it all right when
did you know it was going to go bad for
Colorado on Saturday night or Saturday
afternoon I honestly I I had suspicions
before the season
I think they have done so much in
surprising people in the first three
weeks Dion deserves an overwhelming
amount of credit but before the season
the headline was when you overturned
this muscle of your roster at a school
that's a power five school but not one
of the big time Blue Bloods this isn't
Lane kiffin doing this at Ole Miss every
year this isn't Brian Kelly at LSU or
Lincoln Riley at USC where you're going
to be able to draw and still maintain
some of the depth along the lines of
scrimmage that was one of the areas that
was always going to be most difficult
for Colorado and that's what this Oregon
program was built around with Mario
crystal ball is here and Dan Lanning
through now a season and change has done
a really good job developing maintaining
so I had my worries going into this one
and they were confirmed within the first
couple of drives this was as lopsided a
battle along the offensive and defensive
lines of scrimmage as I've ever seen in
person at a football game any problem
with Oregon giving the appearance they
were running up the score
no no at all and I don't think there's a
single player on Colorado's team
including Deion Sanders their coach that
would either I always said as a player I
never cared about those end game
politics if you're bashing our heads in
and good enough to go out there and beat
us it's my job to stop you it's our job
to stop you Dion Sanders at his core is
a Bowden guy he's an old school coach
and so I'm sure that same second
sentiment's been echoed this is about us
and about us needing to respond to this
so no I have zero problem with that Dan
Lanning and Company had an opportunity
all the conversation was about Colorado
all the coverage is about Colorado and
this was going to be their entrance I
think into the national conversation
they announced it with authority they
know what this is you got to do some
politicking in college football in the
playoff era what do you expect this next
weekend with Colorado and USC
I don't know if there's an amount of
points big enough that you could give me
now I'll say this it won't look as ugly
on one side right shoulder Sanders I
felt terrible for in this game he was
under duress pretty much every drop back
and he came into that game hit more than
any quarterback in college football
sacked more than any quarterback in
college football and that continued as
Oregon put up historic numbers in that
category USC's defense we know isn't
going to put up that same kind of
resistance so I expect chidur Sanders in
this offense even without Travis Hunter
to be able to move the ball against USC
but on the other side for Caleb Williams
in that offense they're going to
continue to be a buzz saw it's what
they've always been so this is the
reality check I think for people that
were parachuting in on this that weren't
necessarily familiar with the realities
around college football because Dan as
you know the Pac-12 probably the deepest
conference in terms of competitors in
college football this year as we get
into October and November yeah my
favorite game over the weekend was
Oregon state Washington State I thought
it was so much fun and I don't know how
many people watched it but again that
was great the ending of Notre Dame and
Ohio State was great you being a former
uh Notre Dame offensive lineman Ryan Day
calling out Lou Holtz you know
questioning the physicality of Ohio
State but as I said a couple of times
already Ohio State's physicality has
been questioned when you lose to Alabama
when you lose to Clemson when you lose
back to back to Michigan yes it should
be questioned Notre Dame Ohio State came
down to what in your opinion
uh one team making the plays the other
didn't everyone's going to focus on
Notre Dame having 10 players on the
field the last two plays of that game
which is inexcusable for the coaching
staff Marcus Freeman Al golden the
defensive coordinator and the veteran
players there's enough old heads on that
defense in key spots where somebody
should have noticed at some point and
didn't but you look there were multiple
dropped interceptions by DJ Brown Notre
Dame safety there were multiple fourth
and one opportunities with a great
offensive line and a big bodied running
back for somebody to go out there and
make the play you had the ball up 14-10
with a chance to run out clock with
three or four minutes left and instead
take a loss on first down and start
throwing stop the clock and do Ohio
State a bunch of favors they gutted this
one out well yes the questions about
toughness compared to Prior regime
compared to their most heated rival in
Michigan I think were the impetus for
all this right Lou holtz's wrong place
wrong time octogenarians I don't think
in general have to hide from Ryan day I
think this was the straw that broke the
Camelback he's probably heard it from
his own fans because when you lose that
game we saw on the other side when Jim
Harbaugh was losing that game it didn't
matter how many of the rest you win or
how you did it if you don't beat that
team things are going to go badly for
you and the fan base is going to start
calling for your head so I'm sure Ryan
day's been sick of hearing about that
from everybody but the toughness really
did Shine through for his team and not
in some of the questionable fourth down
calls or decision making I look squarely
at you're a reflection of your best
players and Marvin Harrison Jr is your
best player and after he went down with
that ankle injury in the middle of that
game I was worried about him for the
next couple of weeks we've all seen
ankle injuries but that one got clipped
and rolled up from behind in a way that
looked devastating and that man went in
the blue tent patted that thing and
taped it up and came back out wasn't
just decoy he was at Target for them and
I think that's something you can point
to if you're Ryan day as a reflection of
these are the leaders and people we're
counting on in this team who found a way
to grid out one of the best wins in
college football on the road this
weekend he's Mike Golic Jr he's co-host
of uh golo a Gojo and Golic my bad Gojo
and Golic on DraftKings Network and uh
he was on the call with Colorado and
Oregon
Alabama's uh demise maybe greatly
exaggerated there they picked up a win
not
not pretty but then I don't you know we
do give style points in college football
but what do you take away from Alabama
winning this game
yeah well and I think we're used to
style points with Alabama really oddly
enough since the guy across the field
coaching Ole Miss got to Tuscaloosa and
Lane kiffin back in the day this had
been a Payson space offense they had
taken what was the big 12 moniker for so
many years and applied it to the SEC
West they had had back to back to back
Heisman candidates and Heisman winning
quarterbacks first round draft picks at
that spot and wide receivers like Jalen
waddle and Devonta Smith that Lit Up
scoreboards and it's been anything but
this year it's been more reminiscent or
at least I think morphing and trying to
morph back into well as at one time
Alabama's Mo the boa constrictor we
talked about for years I think they've
got the Personnel to live more like that
and I think now that they've settled on
the quarterback situation Jalen milro is
going to be the guy he should be the guy
I get why they had the flirtation and
had to try the other two players but I
also get why Jalen milro was going to be
the right choice they've got to decide
if they're going to be the offensive old
that quite frankly fits more with what
Tommy Reese their offensive coordinator
his identity was coming in to this
season from his time at Notre Dame
multiple tight ends ground and pound
hand the ball off behind one of the
biggest bodied offensive lines in
college football and prosper that way as
opposed to trying and living to live and
die with so many big plays the way we
saw them try and go blow for blow with
Texas and Tuscaloosa a couple weeks back
I'll leave you with this the NFL the
oddest result of the NFL so far this
weekend was what
the oddest result so far
I would probably say it's got to be the
Cardinals handing it to Dallas and I get
that
the Dallas Cowboys walked into this game
down Tyler beatish and Zach Martin they
ended up holding Tyron Smith out with a
hamstring injury also so three starters
down in an offensive line that I think
had quietly rebuilt itself into one of
the best in the NFL over the last number
of Seasons but this Cardinals team you
could really say for them the entirety
of the start of this season they've been
a tough out in first half they pushed
around a New York Giants defensive front
that's got some dudes on it last week
too and this week they were just able to
finish the job and as we had spent time
rightly giving Mike McCarthy his flowers
for what he's done with that offense Dan
Quinn in the defense looking like the
best in the NFL we heard Dak Prescott
sort of blame the media after saying you
guys had built us up but I think rightly
so with what they had on defense that
Firepower with Michael Parsons and that
crew up front and Arizona who we had
penciled in for the Caleb Williams or
Drake May sweepstakes has so far pushed
back Josh Dobbs has been exactly what
they've needed at that spot coming over
on week one so I think the Cardinals
have been a wild ride so far this season
and are going to continue to be get
tough out for people when you played at
Notre Dame how much of playing for Notre
Dame is embracing that people are going
to hate you
a lot of it like Duke basketball you
know you know that they either tune in
to watch you win or they tune in to
watch you lose
yeah oh you embraced that right off the
bat I mean listen on the list of things
that you can go and hang your hat on
there you're not in a conference so
you're not not going out there with the
goal of playing a conference
Championship every year you know what
makes you different you know the goal
being national championship and that
goal having eluded us for a long time
makes you the target for a lot of things
there but no you learn pretty quickly on
that you're one of those brand name
programs and I think that's why you come
there though you don't go to a place
like that without recognizing hey
there's a ton of good that can come from
that and look no further than Sam
Hartman what being a top-notch
quarterback for the first time in a
while and South Bend is done that guy's
been a rock star so far this season but
people also step up and be the first to
tear you down it's been a little
different Dan and I've been super
uncomfortable with how nice people have
been since Marcus Freeman took over as
the head coach I kept feeling like I was
getting pumped like people were gonna
jump out and tell me the joke was up
finally but it's still always going to
be a polarizing spot because they're
different and different usually never
goes over well see Deion Sanders in
Colorado right now good to talk to you
Mike thanks for joining us thanks for
having me Dan appreciate it Mike Golic
Jr part of learfield college football's
coverage and it's a Gojo and Golic on
DraftKings Network former Notre Dame
offensive lineman